is sleeping around different for men and
for women it's the same like it's just
as bad
i don't think yeah someone's worse like
everyone is the same
for sure why why because
it's like a man has the key and a woman
is a padlock right
and
you know you don't want not every kid
can open a padlock right so you have to
be special that sleeping around is
different for men and for women yes in
some ways why uh because it's more
normalized while it's not right i think
it's equally not right in both
situations but for men it's more
normalized so it's more of like their
society and it's seen as okay yeah it's
not different you know kinda like i'm
gonna tell you saying yeah you know they
bat the guy you can't trust him yeah
she like bad money you know what i'm
saying yeah
this girl miss i can't lie you can't
trust these women out here you know i'm
saying
it's just a true fact
body count matter to you if you're
interested in a guy and is he how many
bodies is too many bodies for you to
date a guy five five
five so how old are you guys
yeah okay okay so so if you dated a guy
that was five years older and he said
i've slept with 10 women you would be
out yes bye
run run go ronnie we got some wholesome
women out here
oh god yeah i mean i wouldn't want to
end up
how many bodies is too many bodies oh i
don't know i i i don't know and i could
be said if he said i've slept with 50
women would you care no it depends how
old he is as well how old are you a
woman never tells her right okay let's
say let's say he's 45 50 45. i mean it
depends what his lifestyle was as well
yeah you know there's so many factors
that come into that but i just wouldn't
want a star or anybody that just sleeps
with anything i'm with you
you're not trying to catch
so if you were dating a guy or like
you're looking to date a guy do you care
how many people he slept with it really
depends actually what do you mean i mean
if he's still into sleeping around and
he's not willing to commit then yeah i
do care but if he's committed then maybe
not but like it passed you don't think
matters as much for him yeah not too
much you think body count matters in
general no not really would you
would you say your body count
no
but it's interesting because if it
doesn't matter why don't we all just say
it i'm actually saving myself for
marriage oh i love that that's so sweet
i wish i did that okay uh why do you
think that women are looked more down
upon for sleeping around than men in
general because you're atypical from the
responses i've gotten today i think
because guys they get hyped up for it
whereas when we get brought down because
they're like oh you slept with so many
man whereas men they're like yeah come
on like they get ready for it
and there's always things like that
women can't do you get it just like for
example football like oh one can't do
that
but like
yeah
i don't know why we look
i don't know
yeah it's just weird yeah it's weird but
it's just the same like i don't care
okay what would you rate yourself one to
ten eleven
what did you say that that's saying
you're perfect said again what did you
say that's saying you're perfect well my
son's a good eleven then like there's no
room to improve all right well i'm
perfectly imperfect how about that i'll
say a five yeah i'll say five i'll say
i'll stay with seven seven five because
everyone all the girls i asked today say
tens i don't think you no
yourself
there's improvements that i need to
change like i need to change some stuff
about myself
i'm not gonna no
it's a five you say i say five two and i
actually i would like i would put you
above a five but like
but that's what i'm saying like i think
if if you think you're perfect like
there's no room to improve can you never
improve you'll just assume that you're
always perfect no i can't agree you guys
you haven't been any instagrams i feel
like my fans will like you my instagram
what's my instagram i
it's run a car so i t s r o n i c k a
and mine is janae j e n a e underscore
xoxo so how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to wife a girl oh
i miss i missed her i don't know who's
this is to you
well i'm going to be roving 50 plus is
too much
but she will never tell you a girl like
50.
she went over to the truth though the
galley he thinks he's the undertaker 50
buddies
will never take the truth okay okay so
so if she has 30 you're cool with that
nah
no because honestly like i feel like
people should be like girls should be
virgins
yeah i wish i was but i'm not
okay okay so how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to wife or girl i'm
saying like 10 15 man 15 too much man
okay so next next question what do you
rate yourselves one to ten i'm at ten
your time
are you sure i'll be very blunt i'll be
very blunt
okay thank you thank you
all right take off the sunglasses i'll
tell you one to ten
you can't be mad at me you can't be mad
at me
just you know i'm just i'm just going to
tell you i'm going to tell you so this
is how i rate people eight to two i'm
gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you my
system eight to ten means you're a model
that means you would get a modeling
contract five is oh five is normal most
people are five six is cute i don't give
sevens because everyone thinks they're
seven i probably i'd probably give you
five six
oh okay that's cool
to be fair i give nice but to be fair
[Applause]
here's the thing here's the thing they
always ask me to rate them and they
don't want me to do it they don't want
me to do it
how many bodies is too many bodies for
you to wife a girl i don't think too
many bodies would be a thing it's up to
a personal choice if a person is okay
and open about it up front in the in the
relationship and and i'm okay with that
you wouldn't care if she like had a
hundred no i've been with someone who
has had over 200. oh gee and i didn't
bother you at all no why why well but
historically men wanted to ensure
paternity so i think there's some like
biological imperative that men typically
you might be atypical but typically have
when it comes like they're repulsed by
girls that sleep around right right so
when you talk to me like it's just
atypical right yeah sorry i i will be
the odd one out here because a lot of
men like to be the one to you know get
this girl pregnant first or get this
girl in a relationship first but that
that's that's not possible you know
that's it's not natural nor
either way so it's like you when you get
into relationship with someone yeah
you're in that relationship because of
who they are not because of who they've
been with or what experiences that they
had coming in but you don't think that
says something about a girl like a lack
of self-control no i don't think so no
because that's just the experience that
they've gone through everyone's
different so whatever circumstances that
they had to go through to get there
could be different from your own i
actually i understand that mindset but
like the thing is when i started looking
at the numbers i just feel like i i
couldn't not like if a girl sleeps with
more than five people she is at 80
percent um she has a 20 chance of not
being happy in her marriage after 10
years where if she's only she's a virgin
when she gets married she has a 20 she
has an 80 chance of being happy
interesting i think that's a lack of
experience only because they don't want
to venture outside of that comfort zone
well it's a lack of comparison
i would say yeah because like if you're
one of a hundred like what are what are
the odds that like you're going to be
the ones she wants to be with um like
she's comparing you to 100 dude it's
pretty slim but if you're only comparing
the sexual prowess then that would be
one aspect but if you're comparing to
how you make that person feel or what
you can add to that person's life it's
completely different yeah but like as a
girl like i think i feel like a guy has
to be at a certain level for you to
sleep with him so you have to like have
some sort of emotional attachment
because like you're not sleeping with a
fat bum
you know do what i mean but i do i do
well so when you say a certain level are
you talking about uh a certain income
level or are you talking about uh
emotional level i would say it depends
but i'm saying a guy has to have
something like like you you're what five
ten 5 11. yeah yeah so i'm saying like
more girls are going to sleep with you
because you're tall really yeah because
you're fine like that's 5 11 that's
pretty that's the top that's that's not
a few friends who are five five and they
they sleep around with a lot of girls
well maybe they're hot like they have to
have something like i don't i don't know
what it is but i'm saying like that's
something that makes you like i would
never hook up with a guy that was five
five like it wouldn't even never never
but like like six foot like my height
ish like that's that's fine but i'm
saying like you have to have something
as a guy you can't be broke and be a
loser and get girls true true definitely
like income is a very
heavy factor in that in that aspect but
also you have to look at the potential
you have for growing as a person is this
person going to be good for you in the
long run is this person going to help
you with your career is this person
going to help you with your passions is
this person going to help you become the
better you
or are you just trying to fulfill a
certain
you know pleasure aspect are you just
trying to fulfill a certain carnal
aspect are you just trying to fulfill
something that's going to fill a void in
this time or period if so then it's only
going to be temporary if not then you're
looking for something deeper no i i
agree with you like i think it's bad
when girls just go after guys for money
alone but but at the same time like i
think there's some innate
instinct we have that we want a guy
that's more competent than us and that's
why you see like girls that are lawyers
marry another lawyer or doctor like even
the most accomplished women that don't
have money doesn't have anything to do
with it like they still want a guy that
is their income or higher right well i
mean there's nothing wrong with seeking
someone who's going to benefit you in
some way that you don't see because
that's just a natural instinct of trying
to look for success but at the same time
you can find that elsewhere it doesn't
have to be where you're looking do you
think it's natural for men to not want a
girl that sleeps around because just
historically they had to ensure
paternity
true true um i depend
that's a hard question uh i i think it
depends on what you're looking for or
sorry this this male is looking for in a
particular wife
true yeah if they're looking for a wife
then maybe they might not want to yeah
or if they're looking for a quick fling
then that's probably something that
they'll do yeah so if you had a daughter
like would you care if she's would you
encourage her to sleep around or would
you would you
ah i would encourage her to make the
best decisions that she can make with
the information she has at hand only
because like that's how
strong
experience is made